[Music]
what's up believe nation happy weekend
how you doing I wanted to share
something that's all I did for the wife
Janine I suggested that we make a video
on this because we needed something to
share with you guys and so this was her
idea and looks very hot in here cuz
you're on your toes yep I knew it I knew
she doesn't owe you then you know like
points our entire condo this bullet
points and as soon as that they get too
full she gets some way to friends so
that she can grow more plants right you
would look even today we had friends
over and she gave them dirt to go home
with me a lesson plans and in the
wintertime is uh it's harder because she
can't grow as much stuff we have a
balcony outside and she likes to grow
stuff but in the winter which you can't
do that so I decided to do something
special for her and help build her a
little indoor plant the Sun indoor play
I enjoy quieter us a little about you
know we actually really showed the
previous one we will ask for help to
grow my plants indoors since I'm sorry
but but not much going on should i
update again is the update this is what
I built we got to stand up desk it at
the top Nina has her keyboard that she
plays piano on and then underneath we've
got these growing lights and a big grow
light and then in here she's growing her
plants that are just starting to come up
what are you growing in here this one is
the i think is either cucumber zucchini
cucumber zucchini you good is often feed
right yeah and then this is tomato
tomato tomato tomato tomato and Cal Cal
Cal Cal Cal and then sage sage and then
my avocado plant look at that thing is
getting big yeah what kind of Kathleen
but look how much is group hey Joey
value
so the lesson for this weekend is be a
good husband see something good for you
with the wife okay which it or just just
do something nice for somebody maybe you
know like why why she do great very nice
things about function to and making
yummy other guys is very important cool
cookie cookie could cut a little cookie
will cook you yummy free every day she
does have jumping food you can check out
a youtube channel with some good stuff
on there all right thank you guys for
joining us in this impromptu amazing
short video we believe in you we hope
you continue to believe in yourself and
whatever your armor it is what season
Jesse much love my boys love I'll see
you soon would see you soon